y'all it is wild out here it is wild
being a woman because listen I am 1
million per for women's rights I think
about it actually all the time I have
two daughters um but what I also think
about a lot of the times is that like I
don't want to do it anyway you know like
I'm glad that we now can drive cars but
I don't want to drive I don't want to
drive but I don't want you telling me I
can't do it I also don't want you to do
something because I'm a woman thinking
that I can't do it myself um but then I
think it's you should do it for me like
when I'm unloading something from the
car that's heavy and and a man sees me
unloading it like I I I don't want him
to assume that I can't do it on my own
but if he doesn't help me that was rude
that was really rude cuz I don't want to
do it by myself and it was Heavy you
know there's a problem there's a problem
this is a problem I'm admitting that and
the first step is admitting that you
have a problem also like do not think
for me I can think on my own but please
don't ask cuz I don't want to use my
brain I don't want to use it I don't
don't want to use it but I want to have
the ability to it is confus it is wild
out here being a woman is crazy crazy or
maybe I'm just crazy but either way
she's 100% right it is
crazy
100% you want all those things but you
also don't want to do none of those
things I get it confusing as [__] and
it's wild to be a
woman imagine dealing with
you
you got to know how to
navigate hence the reason why man shut
the [__] up most of the times what you
thinking one I'm not thinking about
nothing two but
also there's no right answers here none
so yeah agreed it is wild and I can
understand that you want to be able I
you want to be able to know that you you
can pay the
bills but we're not going to split that
bill but I can pay
it but I don't want to I understand it's
called choices it's it's real it's real
[__] yeah do you ever feel that way
about being like a stay at home dad like
you want the ability to be able to do it
but you don't want to do it you don't
you don't do not put me in a box I want
to go in that box but don't tell me I
should go in that box I go in that box
if I want to be in that box facts you
know I feel that way I feel that way
about being a provider I don't mind
providing for a lady but don't tell me
but don't tell me that's my job but but
yeah yeah don't tell me it's like it's
like you know I'll pay but don't come up
with your
house assuming that you I think she's we
might all know it but [__] you ain't
got to say it cuz it's disrespectful if
you shut the [__] up about it I'll
gladly do it it's like I don't I don't
tell my girl to make me a sandwich in
the kitchen because she likes me she
does but it's just rude to be like yo go
in the [__] kitchen make me a or even
even even worse she goes she makes a s
like yeah you doing your job yeah that's
hey whoa but she going to be I'm going
to go to the B I'm going to go to the
I'm going to go to the kitchen I'm going
to make I'm going make a sandwich you
want a sandwich yeah yeah but I wanted a
sandwich I don't have to say it I don't
have to be rude about it so there's
nothing wrong with what she says I
actually think she's speaking what most
people
say and it's title of this video is oh
my god a woman just solved the red pill
just kid that's not what it is
that's yeah I just for no reason whether
whether it's social engineering
biological or a mixture of both I think
a lot of us gravitate towards a lot of
norms that have been here pre the
explosion of employment opportunity
birth control and all these other things
so there's a lot of stuff that we still
stick with when it comes to Traditional
Values and like it's very conflicting
because a lot of the messaging is we're
breaking down these things all this
stuff and I think it's great that we
have the option to but the truth is a
lot of us still go back to a lot of
those NES even the most Progressive
places you know take my girl Destiny she
still pays for all the dates even though
you know her and her wife or ex-wife you
know what I mean made a lot of money
both like she was still expected to pay
because why even in the most Progressive
of areas a lot of the people still stick
to a lot of those same Norms so yeah
it's like it's like it's it's a human
nature o if you're if you're stopped by
you go straight to biology if you stop
if you're getting stopped by the police
watch if you go stopped by or a security
guard tells yo go over there if you if I
push you you're going to be like hey
don't [__] touch me I was going
you're going to you're going to want to
resist doing that you're going to be
like hey don't [__] push me like yo
can you go over there please yeah go I'm
going if you're being told you're going
to be more reluctant to go me personally
I'm not like that cuz I'm a sigma male
so me when you push me I'm like thanks
for the assistance you
know like you know what I mean like like
are you do from behind o thanks like
like I I I go with it I don't even fight
it
mhm but I understand what you're saying
for the regular Alpha and betas go ahead
I was
[Music]
then that annoyed me so much when you
went sing with ma that annoyed
me so much
bro I went over here and I went uh you
disgusting human being I just oh thanks
for the assistant I want G kill yourself
oh my God I apolog I'm sorry no you're
fine you're fine I
know you like you like you like the
trigger [__] or too you're fine
it's it's it's okay okay you're good you
know you know the red pill stuff is not
actually the first time I heard about
the sigma male stuff cuz I used to be
part of a fraternity called Sigma Sigma
Sigma and that fraternity talked about a
lot of the alpha beta gamma stuff really
that's not anyways never mind yeah you
know the symbol for Sigma right yeah
what is it uh the symbol for Sigma
is uh well Sigma the letter
Sigma is it not um the S like this with
two lines no that's dollar sign
all right let's finish this video Sigma
looks like a pointy e but whatever all
right let's finish this video um yes so
what would
you where the [__] is this
going the is wrong with you bro okay
sorry my apologies Jesus Christ I had
some ketamine earlier you to k i me bro
don't say it so loud you said it so loud
we heard you when you said it yeah but
when I say it's okay when you do it it
feels oppressive it is okay so you do
some K listen I don't mind doing it I
don't like the way you saying it when I
do
it what we did there got you I was a
addict
true don't say that they're going to run
off and be like true they already think
we get high before every episode that's
so true like I don't even smoke ever and
you're like whoa y'all must have been
buned out that that is y'all must have
been bunned out y'all haven't so I have
fun sober stupid that's that's so facts
yeah you've been having a CAC bottle on
youring desk for the past month it
hadn't even been open it hasn't even
been open stop cing it hasn't been open
I'm taking three shots that's open
that's clearly open yeah that's open
okay but it's been like that for the
past month you know sometimes I don't
even drink it you know what I do I
woo why what who does that
me I'm not I'm I'm not one of these ones
I'm one of these you know what I'm
saying like I don't know what the [__]
that was cuz you know some people be Dr
I'm not what what's that none of those
I'm drinking the wi none of those signs
are Universal I understand you know H
you know people drink a wine like this
and they and they're So Graceful may I
do but I spill a little bit on myself
yes you spill most of the so I'm an
alcoholic Drinker all right but I'm not
graceful about it I'm not cool about it
how yeah I think I understand the
wanting the rights to be able to do
something just not being told you can
plenty things in the world that I don't
want to be barred from not because it's
me or anything like that but because I
just don't think it's right for people
to be barred on any basis of gender or
whatever it might be so even though guys
were probably hitting me up with this
and be like Oh ladies are
crazy I don't think it's that crazy it's
not that crazy it's not that crazy
because there are some women who do
really want to drive and do want to be
able to get the cars and they should
have the right to and there are some
women who do want to be cosos and work
and they should have the right to right
all of them should have the ability to
but as far as whether or not they want
to exercise it that's a whole different
story anything else you want to say like
I don't really want to go skydiving but
if I was told I couldn't I'd be like
that's kind of stupid you know they say
like oh only white people can go
skydiving like why you know me not that
I want to go but why can't we go I want
to sit in the back of the bus most of
the time don't tell me to go there there
you go anyways so that's it for today's
video let us know what you guys think in
the
comments